[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Joshua Lynne a visiting fellow at the
Center for the Study of representative
institutions at the Macmillan Center and
a lecturer in the history department he
studies 19th century politics culture
and political thought in the United
States with particular attention to the
interaction of race gender and
conservatism in the antebellum political
culture today we'll talk with Professor
Lynn about his forthcoming book
preserving the white man's Republic the
Democratic Party and the transformation
of American conservatism from 1847 to
1860 welcome professor Lynn hi Thank You
Marilyn let's start with an overview of
your book tell us about it sure my book
is a history of the Democratic Party the
United States Democratic Party in the
late 1840s and 1850s immediately
preceding the American Civil War and I'm
interested in charting how this party
transitioned into becoming a
self-identified conservative party with
a set of political ideas they called
conservative
and so I examine their political thought
their political ideas but I also examine
their cultural beliefs especially their
attitudes towards gender race the family
and the household and I put those in
dialogue and what I ultimately find is
that Democrats in the 1840s and 1850s
they took their traditional dedication
to majoritarian democracy a belief in
local grassroots self-government and
they rebranded it as conservative
because they were worried that the
Republic that they had built which was a
republic of political equality for white
men was threatened by a generation of
American reformers especially
anti-slavery Americans and other
reformers who they thought would expand
the body politic to invite in Americans
of color and women and so they took
their dedication to democracy and called
it conservative and argued that
democratically allowing white men to
democratically govern themselves would
actually prevent this type of change it
preserve Whiteman's monopoly of
political power and in the process they
injected democracy into the American
conservative tradition and transformed
American conservatism okay so what led
you to this topic what I was looking
through sources
I noticed repeatedly the use of the word
conservative and it was surprising for a
group of politicians that had previously
not been considered conservative the
Democratic Party created in the late
1700s by Thomas Jefferson and then sort
of re-energized by Andrew Jackson in the
early 1800s was not a conservative party
and was not regarded by American
conservatives as a conservative party
this was a party that believed in
democracy believed in individual natural
rights for white men that caveat is very
important and believed and other
enlightenment teachings about natural
equality for white men following the
principles of thinkers like John Locke
and these were not conservative beliefs
and many American conservatives saw the
Democratic Party as the radical party in
America and the Democrats themselves saw
themselves as the Progressive Party they
felt that their mission was to spread a
Galit areand democracy and political
rights for all white men and so I was
struck by suddenly in the 1840s and
1850s the use of the word conservative
in reference to themselves and I was
curious what that meant and the topic of
conservatism has produced a lot of rich
scholarship among American historians
and political scientists recently mostly
on conservatism in the 20th century
especially after World War two trying to
account for what's happened in our
politics today the triumph of grassroots
electoral conservatism and the new right
so I was curious if any connections
could be made between the rich
scholarship on twentieth-century
conservatism and these folks in the 19th
century who were calling themselves
conservatives okay and how did you do
the research for the book so I looked at
two sets of sources and put them in
conversation I looked at manuscript
sources unpublished writings by
Democrats from all walks of life
throughout the country in the mid 19th
century so the diaries letters
unpublished writings personal
recollections
and I also put and I put them alongside
more formal published sources so
political treatises pamphlets campaign
speeches congressional records and
newspapers and I was because I because I
was interested in getting at the
political thought of an entire party not
a few select individuals not a few
theorists or thinkers but the party as a
whole and I wanted to cast a wide net
and also including sources like songs
political campaign songs political
cartoons to get at how these ideas
percolated throughout all ranks of the
party and in doing so I found that what
Democrats said maybe in the legislature
in debates and on the stump mirrored
what they believed personally and what
they wrote about privately to one
another and their political beliefs were
rooted in their daily lives and their
cultural expectations their cultural
assumptions their views of themselves as
men as white men as masters of their
households and I made sure to include
both northern and southern democrats a
nationwide study which hadn't been done
before for the democrats in this period
because the democrats even on the eve of
the Civil War managed to hold together a
coalition of white men from the slave
states and the free states even as the
nation was about to split over the topic
of slavery they managed to forge this
alliance of white men interested in
preserving their rights and maintaining
their exclusive access to democratic
power ok earlier you had mentioned that
things had been different prior to the
time period that you're looking at can
you are there what are your thoughts in
terms of why things change to become
more conservative the party itself
becomes more conservative because to
some extent they felt they had
accomplished their animating mission
they they had achieved by the 1840s they
had achieved white male suffrage for all
white men in the United States they had
achieved what they considered to be the
perfect Republic they often refer to
their Republic as perfect as exceptional
there's a lot of American Exceptionalist
rhetoric in this era they called it the
happy Republic they had achieved so they
had achieved a republic in which all
white men had
rights could participate fully in
decision-making and in which they remove
the government from white men's lives to
give white men more power and autonomy
and power over other Americans and they
also had achieved in foreign policy a
continent-wide Republic this is after
the mexican-american war and the
conquest of new territory so this they
had achieved what they considered in
global terms and a expansive Republic
and a novel Republican that they had
achieved something that had not been
achieved before a complete democracy
which for them of course meant for white
men right so who were some of the
players political players during this
time period so the the political players
in this time period are some sort of the
the the lesser presidents and lesser
statesmen this is the 1840s and 1850s if
you're looking at Democrats is somewhat
this dead period it's the period between
Andrew Jackson and maybe and then the
ascendancy of Lincoln and the
Republicans and so it hasn't received a
lot of attention it's seen as a time of
mediocre politicians so the Democratic
presidents of the 1850s are Franklin
Pierce and James Buchanan who were
always ranked at the bottom in
presidential rankings and so this is
seen as an era in which the party is not
as exuberant not as exciting not as
intellectual as its founding generation
with Andrew Jackson and his general and
his supporters so for that reason it
doesn't receive a lot of attention even
though these Democrats were thinkers
they may not have been the best
political thinkers but they are
producing a lot of ideas writing about
their thoughts and there are some who
are who should be reconsidered as
important to American political theory
especially someone like Stephen Douglas
the senator from Illinois
who is one of the most vocal proponents
of using democracy as a conservative
tool in the 1850s and he's one that
helps lead this transition okay so you
look at the interaction of things like
race and gender can you excite some
specific examples of how gender and race
play into what was going on at that time
when the the Democrats one of their
worst fears
was the opening of the political sphere
to women and Americans of color and this
is why they they switch from their
progressive mission of expanding the
political sphere once they had included
all white men including ethnic
minorities like Irish and German
immigrants and Catholics when they have
accomplished that they then turned to
closing off that political sphere no one
else can enter they felt that any
expanding rights further mean even more
progressive would be too radical this is
the the origin of their conservative
turn is this fear that going too far
with progress would undermine the rights
already achieved for white men they
didn't believe rights could be extended
indefinitely they adhere to
enlightenment teachings about natural
rights and natural equality for white
men but not for anybody else so this is
a white supremacist party with very
ingrained ideas about race regarding
Native Americans and African Americans
and so they felt that they they felt the
Republic was perfect
an additional tampering with it would
only undermine it and in this era
there's a whole generation of reformers
the anti-slavery movement the
anti-slavery Republican Party
abolitionists but also temperance
reformers women's rights advocates also
health reformers all of whom Democrats
saw as a threat because they would push
progress too far and lead the Republican
to some sort of radical area that they
weren't willing to enter and let's talk
about some of the other political
parties that were active at this time
how how different were they and you know
how did they interact this was an
interesting era of intense political
change and partisan realignment the
1840s in the 1850s
saw the collapse of the existing
American two-party system of Whigs and
Democrats Democrats survived this and
our face with new opponents as their
traditional opponents the Whigs
disintegrate the Republican Party is the
party that emerges victorious and of
course sets us up for our current
political rivalry of Democrats
Republicans and Republicans were the
anti-slavery party but also there was a
nativist and anti-catholic party called
a know-nothing party and Democrats were
terrified of nativism anti-catholicism
the
because they regarded immigrants white
immigrants from Germany and Ireland and
Catholics as fellow white men and they
did not want any nativist prescription
of their rights so they fought nativism
and they fought anti-catholicism she
have this interesting dynamic where you
have a white supremacist party that is
also strongly in favor of the rights of
immigrants naturals naturalization
rights and the rights of religious
minorities especially Catholics because
they extended the prerogatives of
whiteness and political equality to
these fellow white men to help build
their coalition so it's a party of
slaveholders it's a party of urban
ethnic working men in northern cities
it's a party of Catholics all of whom
saw a common bond in preserving their
rights against those who would give
their take away their rights or give
their rights to women or
african-americans so do you think their
political values played a role in the
civil war the Democrats yes absolutely
they they wanted to be the party that
could compromise on issues like slavery
they wanted to be as part of being the
conservative party they wanted to be the
party of the Union that could hold the
Union together north and south and they
felt that by appealing to the interests
of white men regardless of whether those
white men were northern or southern
slaveholders or anti-slavery Catholic or
Protestant immigrant or native born that
they could achieve this and this leads
them to this sort of hands-off approach
to moral issues where all white men
should be able to lead their lives in
regards to one issue is temperance so
white men should be able to drink white
men should be able to practice their
religion freely and white men should be
able to own other human beings if they
wanted to so this is sort of moral
almost relativism mm-hmm what was their
value so basically anything goes
anything a white man wanted to do would
be okay so to a large degree they they
run into barriers to what would be the
logical extension of their thought and
so for example Mormons in Utah Territory
in the legalization of polygamy
Democrats couldn't stomach that it was
too unpopular in the American electorate
so they would let slave hole
move west and have slavery in new
territories but they wouldn't let
Mormons have polygamy and that's and
it's really it's it's a logical
inconsistency but so there are some
places where they wouldn't go okay do
you see any similarities and today
basically in terms of some of the values
affecting you know the politics of today
I see the Democrats in the 1850s in
pioneering this style where you take
away power from the government and
devolve power to local communities of
white men as a conservative tool I see
that as a style that has entered
American conservatism and we see it
repeatedly their their thought process
behind this was democracy which had been
considered unstable and radical for
centuries as a political as a mechanism
mechanism of governance could be
conservative if white men were given
democratic power the assumption was they
wouldn't forfeit their power by giving
it to others so they could be trusted to
rule themselves through grassroots
democracy and the best example of this
and that has parallels to the present is
this doctrine of what Democrats called
popular sovereignty in the 1850s which
was their hallmark political doctrine
which held that white male settlers in
federal territories should be the ones
who would decide if they would have
slavery or not and if slavery would
spread and be legal in new territories
like Kansas like Utah like New Mexico
Nebraska and the thought process was
this is conservative because white men
on the ground in those places knew their
interests better than the elite in DC or
reformers or political parties and they
could be trusted to make their own
decisions and they want to be radical
because at the end of the day they have
their own rights that's at stake and so
you see this as a style in American
politics continuing to the present in
the current election is being used by
some of the supporters of Donald Trump
to be taken as a vindication of the
people against the know-it-alls in
Washington the elites who said he
couldn't win
and so this sort of same rhetoric of
devolve empower to the people but it's
who would use democracy to conserve
something not to affect change or
achieve social justice okay
so ultimately what do you conclude in
the book and and what's what would you
like people to take away from your book
the one of the big conclusions is that
democracy can be conservative and that
had not been before but Democrats
pioneered this style and that democracy
which is often associated with
liberalism with the recive ISM with
social justice affecting change today
today yes but democracy is neutral
democracy can be anything depending on
who wields it democracy is pure power
and it can be used for conservative ends
the democratic process can be used to
prevent change to withhold rights to
thwart social justice and an example
today would be regarding rights for
LGBTQ Americans in same-sex marriage
this idea that even if the executive the
judiciary and the legislature all sign
off on rights that there's this higher
threshold the people have to vote on it
and often when the people are invoked to
vote on things regarding the rights of
LGBTQ Americans it's on the assumption
that they'll vote it down so even when
all branches of the government legalized
maybe same-sex marriage or extend rights
to a certain group some conservatives
can rely on the people say we need to
and this is this is too big an issue for
politicians to decide that people must
vote on and so just as Democrats wanted
the people to vote on whether or not
African Americans should be enslaved we
have the same style today where the
people can be invoked on issues of
constitutional rights where rights and
fundamental equality is put up to the
electorate sometimes in hopes that the
electorate will not extend those rights
and so I see that as a legacy of the
Democratic Party and as one of the big
takeaways of this of my book is that
this is a a political style that's been
with us for a long time and that it
really should make us rethink our
reflexive urge to look at democracy as
always a progressive
and beneficial mechanism okay very
interesting thank you for being here
with us today thank you Marilee for more
information about professor Lin and his
research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
[Music]